do I sound crazy quiet on set
hello this is not tasty this is my
personal kitchen in light of recent
events and the state of the world all of
us at tasty are going to be working and
cooking from home so today I'm going to
be reviewing some onion cutting gadgets
that I found on the internet in order to
make some foods that are going to
hopefully tide myself my roommates over
for the coming weeks and we'll see how
they work we'll see if they work and
we'll see if they're worth buying so
without further ado let's get started
roll up my sleeves alright so the first
gadget I'm going to be looking at today
is a stainless steel onion holder this
is by a company called newness sort of
looks like like a comb so the idea is
that it sort of gets your fingers out of
the way so you're not in danger of
cutting yourself while you're chopping
onions and I guess you can also use it
as a way of cutting more precisely so
I'm going to be using this to help me
cut up a bunch of yellow onions because
I'm going to be making a whole batch of
caramelized onions that I can use on
sandwiches and breakfast and a whole
variety of things so for frame of
reference I'm going to chop just one
yellow onion to start it's not sliding
away from me it's not moving around the
cutting board I'm not having that heart
of the time so I don't know how much
better this is going to make it so we
have our control onion here so now I'm
going to try out the onion holder and
see if it makes it any easier
the first thing I'm gonna try is I'm
just gonna spear it I think like here
and then see using it strictly as a
holder didn't make it any easier to be
quite honest so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to try now flip it around and
use the teeth of the onion holder to
kind of act as my guide okay I get it
this is cool by using it as a guide and
cutting all along it holds all of my
pieces together so I've got my entire
chopped onion right here and all I can
do is ideally just go so using it as a
guide is obviously the better way so
let's just kind of place through the
last bits of these onions and I can
time-lapse through this
when that is five large yellow onions
sliced up in a matter of minutes do I
think this is an absolute necessity no
but this is a really good way of kind of
ensuring that everything is uniform so
with that being said I'm going to set
these guys aside and move on to my next
test so the next little gadget I'm going
to be looking at is this it is a set of
onion goggles now I'm the kind of person
that tears up when I cut onions it's
kind of amazing how I didn't tear up
cutting all those guys right there
and I'm gonna see if these actually work
I'm going to be making a batch of
pickled red onions that I can use on
sandwiches I'll use some love breakfast
bowls I love pickled red onions because
they keep well in the refrigerator
willing to remove my glasses and I can't
see so this'll be a risky you feel like
swimming goggles so there is a little
bit of foam around the outsides that I
think is meant to keep out that onion
odor just give these guys a shot see if
I cry one onion no tears
two onions no twos so besides the whole
not being able to see thing because I
have terrible eyes this is actually
working well last one don't fail me now
goggles I'm not gonna call these the
most fashionable but honestly they work
pretty well I've got two whole red
onions here I'm not crying
if you have a pair of swim goggles you
can easily repurpose those to work as
these but if you don't these are a great
way to get around that whole crying
issue so before I move on to my final
gadget let's get these onions
caramelizing and these onions pickling
and we'll be back at it butter in there
got a little olive oil just soften up
and reduce a little bit so I've got a
mixture of apple cider vinegar and water
with about a tablespoon of sugar salt
some pepper corns
and garlic so I'll bring this up to a
boil and then I'm gonna pour it over my
onions already so my yellow onions have
been caramelized and my red onions are
pickling in the fridge which brings me
to my last onion gadget I'm gonna be
testing today this is the Muller onion
chopper Pro it's sort of a chopper and
containing device all in one so you
don't have to worry about all those
onion odor
is going everywhere you don't have to
worry about cutting your fingers at all
so I'm going to be making a tomato jam
with this I love putting tomato jam on
everything it goes great on sandwiches
toast and eggs in the morning tomato jam
keeps really really well in the fridge
now the packaging for this not only
shows onions but it shows a variety of
other vegetables so I'm going to test it
out on a red onion and I'm also going to
test it out on a bunch of tomatoes that
I've washed so first things first I'm
actually going to set this guy aside
chop my onion in half just to make it a
little bit more manageable I'm using the
smaller blade size for the onions just
cuz I want them to be really fine and
then for the tomatoes I'm going to go
with the larger blade take my onion
place it right on top and that takes
like a fraction of the time it would
take to normally chop something I've
deviously to a bowl here to really easy
to kind of swap out the inside so you
pop this locking mechanism here you take
this guy out and then for my tomatoes
I'm gonna go with a thicker blade let's
pop that guy in and you're good to go
I'm actually going to cut my tomatoes
into more manageable chunks now I'm
gonna place my tomatoes on there and
press and there you have it that is the
Muller onion chopper Pro I'm pretty
impressed with it it's definitely faster
than using a knife my tomatoes look
great everything looks really really
well chopped so all I have to do at this
point is put together my tomato jam and
that's all my onion gadgets done I'm
going to add my tomatoes brown sugar
salt cumin coriander and red pepper
flake and then finally the juice of one
lemon I'm just gonna let that simmer for
a few hours until it's nice and thick
and there you have it I have my pickled
red onions my caramelized yellow onions
and my tomato jam that I made using my
three onion chopping gadgets overall
impressions do I think you need any of
these not really I think the biggest
game-changer for me was the goggles just
because it took what is usually the
biggest problem about cutting onions and
did away with it can you get away with
using a pair of swimming goggles
yeah plus you get more use out of it
when it comes to the two chopping
gadgets I'm a little bit on the fence
the onion holder is great it definitely
makes sort of chopping the same you
for looking pieces super super easy but
I also feel like with practice you
really don't need this finally the
muller onion chopper pro it is really
really handy and it is really really
fast it's also really really bulky plus
this only allows you to cut to different
sizes the vegetables and there's more
components to clean them with a single
knife so at the end of the day how much
time are you actually saving overall I'm
just happy that these gadgets performed
hopefully these will tide my roommates
and I over for a few weeks now if you're
interested in getting these gadgets for
yourself we have affiliate links below
as well as links to all the recipes if
there's any gadgets you want us to test
out let us know in the comments section
below and until then see ya
[Music]